finish this lyric from what dreams are
made of done yeah Hilary Duff foot
meghan trainor to the ultimate Lizzie
McGuire test and reunited with Ethan
Kraft she's worthy so is he is he here
is who here
there's my little friend plate of the
best food in the world this really is
what dreams are made of if have you ever
seen such a beautiful night you know oh
yeah I could almost yeah girl he'll
quizzed self-proclaimed Lizzie superfan
Megan about her classic Disney show and
movie as part of billboards
appropriately named quizzed series and
guys be prepared to be mad impressed
this first is called true or false the
song at Lizzie sings at the beginning of
the movie while her brother Matt records
her is come clean know right you got
that right what so what's the song it's
um oh I loved this song and it was the
first time I heard the song even though
it's a cover the dad is
meagan drops some facts on hillary like
where lizzie and gordo shared their
first kiss where do Gordo and Lizzie
kiss on the on the top on the rooftop
yep yes and how Paulo whisked her away
what kind of vehicle does Paulo pick
Lizzy up on for their first date Bern
broom a red scooter yeah okay Megan
you're officially the biggest Lizzie
McGuire fan we'll give it to you she
honestly might know more than Hillary
who says she's only seen the movie twice
and once was just this year I actually
watched it over the weekend with my son
because I hadn't seen it since the
premiere oh very big portion of my life
that I was like I'm good for a minute
yeah he was in and out but my future
husband my future husband thank you um
he left at the mouth but the best part
of the whole thing was that reunion that
I teased earlier
Clayton Schneider who played Ethan Kraft
in the og show walking in with a plate
of spaghetti
you look like Hercules now this has us
thinking that Ethan Kraft may just pop
up in the Disney Plus revival that
Hilary is currently filming she played
coy about the possibility just a few
weeks ago with et chance that Lizzy's
engaged to Ethan um I don't maybe you
could be helping the writers right now
with some like future plans even and
cave back there right yeah absolutely
yes yes but no she's not currently
engaged to Ethan fast but someone else
like a new a new person like in his
place well you said that Lizzy's engaged
she um I have no idea what you're
talking about
I'm so bad at playing clay I'm like an
open book yeah he has to be back right
so far Disney has only confirmed that
Lizzy's family and her pal Gordo will
return for the new show plus animated
Lizzy guess I'll be going now
[Applause]
animated Lizzy does she have an updated
look I'm like am i giving stuff away I
don't know she's gonna she's gonna say
the same which i think is is the right
thing to do right it's like that pink
top it's so iconic and I clap form flip
flops
yeah those like rocket dog flip flops I
don't know if anyone knows those but
yeah she has an epic return and I'm I'm
so excited for everyone to I think she's
really gonna be a lot of the comic
relief in the show Hillary also said
this now that she's in her 30s what kind
of struggles do we see her go through I
think that was part of the draw for me
of coming back was like the struggles
that I feel of being a 30 year old and
obviously we're in very different places
I'm a mother I'm in a serious
relationship and she has a lot of those
things she has gained a lot of
confidence and she has a really cool
career and you know she's still I think
she's still going to be faced with
challenging things we're in middle
school those challenging things seemed
funny and simple but relatable at the
time and I think now in your 30s it's
gonna be the same way but like slightly
heavier slightly bigger things to deal
with like she doesn't have kids yet and
she you know she there's some surprises
in the first episode that I also don't
want to give away but I think it's
really gonna be fun to go on on the
journey with her at 30 and you know it's
the same Lizzy but she's an adult well
it's safe to say I'll be tuning in of
course you can count on et to spill all
the Hilary Duff Lizzie McGuire T so make
sure to keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Holly Stephens I'll see
you soon
[Music]